I wanted to talk about crypto jacking
right which is I mean the name itself it
started off in a good way sometimes
called drive-by mining also a great name
this is the idea that we can trick
someone instead of maybe putting a virus
on their machine I mean it might still
be a virus but we can trick them into
mining some cryptocurrency for us and
that way we make a profit
think of it like an alternative in crime
sensitive an somewhere where you're
trying to get money off someone by
taking control of their files we're now
just trying to use some of their CPU
power to earn us some money
right Sophie reticle eBay mind some
coins for us they send them to us and
then we we profit from those so
because a company called coin hive
decided maybe instead of showing people
adverts online they could just use a
little bit of s CPU to mind using
cryptocurrency while they're browsing
and that way they don't have to look at
adverts and you still get paid for your
for your website right now that actually
is not a bad idea or in some sense the
idea would be but you go to let's say a
newspaper and instead of seeing a load
of banner ads you see a little ticker
but says you're mining some
cryptocurrency while you're on this
website and you know we're gonna make a
small amount of money off this in
exchange for you not having any ads and
reading the news for free right ok and I
mean the amount of money you're going to
spend for a couple of minutes reading an
article is not very much right if you're
even if your CPUs on a hundred percent
this is JavaScript so you you go to a
website it serves you a script which
instructs your computer to start mining
these coins the problem is that it
wasn't long before people thought well
we don't maybe we should just not ask
permission right we should we should
have them on all the coins all the time
right
and the other thing was that coin hive
has a feature which lets you only use
let's say 60% of a CPU so there's some
overhead for Mouse events and things
that are kind of important to keep the
operating system running and of course
the the malware program is for whatever
100 percent right so I've just got this
web server set up on my machine I've
extended my classic blog this is the
world's best blog of course alright it
looks good we've a nice banner ad which
also happens to mine meme some Manero
cryptocurrency
all right so let's have a look so you
can see here I've got my blog before
it's got my comments and my cat pictures
I had before and it's also got this
lovely banner ad which I made for my
shop she's not a real shot don't send me
any money you will also notice now if
you look at my CPU monitor which I've
also got running it's sitting on 100%
and if we leave it for a minute we're
going to start hearing my fan get louder
and louder
louder because basically the entirety of
my CPU is mining Manero cryptocurrency
now I mean I didn't notice the mouse is
still responding I mean you know said
modern PC but you know you wouldn't
necessarily know apart from the fact you
fit the tannest bun up now
it's also not plugged in so the
battery's going to be draining pretty
fast the good news is but this is
already less common than it was just a
few months ago because Chrome Firefox
you know antivirus been antivirus
vendors and things like this are all
cracking down on these kind of scripts
now coin hive as I pointed out it's
actually legitimate company they weren't
intending on people to be using this
service so they've now got an opt-in
version where a little pop-up turns up
and you can say I do opt-in for this
time instead of ads or something like
this right that isn't blocked by
browsers because that's a legitimate
commercial alternative to ads but of
course coin I've aren't the only people
that are making these folks ever you're
going to have closed you're going to
have malware that does this and you can
just imagine that instead of getting man
somewhere you'll just get something like
this and runs on your PC instead and
it's the same is true also of phones so
you might download an app which seems
too good to be true I was not even any
adverse on this free game and it maybe
it's because it's using up extra of your
CPU to mine cryptocurrency if you were
doing this in Bitcoin you wouldn't you
wouldn't get a look-in essentially I
could mine with my CPU bitcoins you know
for hundreds of years and never get any
right because compared to be the size of
the Bitcoin network we've all their
dedicated Hardware my CPU is a nonentity
essentially Manero is slightly different
Manero has a a hashing function but it
uses in the mining process which is
quite hard to do on a GPU and so you get
some but not a lot of benefit from
having a dedicated rig right two times
maybe given the cost of a graphics card
not very good so actually you could have
a lot of Android phones competing with
big graphics cards in Manero
specifically and and so in some sense
there is a point to do it now that's one
of the reasons it was designed this way
to allow people on phones and things to
mine but it has this benefit that or
benefited depending on who you are that
it's a good target for this kind of
malware right because if you have a
website where everyone is mine
Mineiro for you it's not gonna make you
a huge amount of money but it will make
you some and Manero is one of these
currencies that something a bit hard to
keep a track of and so maybe you can get
away of it that's that's the idea my
browser and my extensions block it my
antivirus on my machine blocks it the
university fire will blocks it so I'm
currently I have all of those disabled
and I'm rooting through my 4G phone
connection it works fine at home
I know good or bad so you know like I
say the vendors of things like
antibodies are taking a lot of steps to
to fix this I'm gonna close this now
because it's it's not that loud actually
it's basically the thing that says many
things will say oh by now that's got
some JavaScript well yeah I mean this is
just an image but yeah just next to it
is some script that does it you could
imagine that if I was running a like a
newspaper website I'm being served ads
by some ad company all I have to do to
get in there is pay some money to have
an advert deployed which also happens to
have this script no one's going to go to
my blog right it's not online but also
because no it's rubbish so what I was an
attacker it would be much smarter for me
to try and take over a where lots of
people are going this became into the
news because in February 2018 an
accessibility website that are just like
screen bleeding and things like this was
hacked and their JavaScript file had
some Manero mining code inserted into it
and this website was serving JavaScript
to about 4000 UK and US government
websites among others including the
Information Commissioner's Office and
various high-level government websites
this meant that when you went on those
web sites to let's say find out about
something important
you were actually mining Manero for the
attackers not ideal could you work out
who did it
absolutely well no all you can all you
know is I mean assuming the wallet all
we know is the address but the the
Monaro is being mined too right and as
usual you've got the traceability issues
of that if they use that address to buy
like pizza to their house it might be
slightly easier to find them but if they
try and hide it it's gonna be harder
this is a code that was inserted into
all these government websites
this is not like code my code is much
simpler than this and it's also not
obfuscated so this has been encoded to
try and make it harder for antivirus to
find and then this is VD office gated
version which is essentially look
up the coin hive JavaScript and then
pointing it towards this address which
you shouldn't mind Manero for because
their malware writers they won't even
write in their own JavaScript where
we're using calling Hans action yeah
yeah I mean he's pretty lazy really yes
so I think now some are writing in
JavaScript or embedding it into Java
apps or Android phones and things like
this but yes when coin high first came
out this was not I would say an
unexpected side effect of their new idea
I like I say they've kind of come up
with a more legitimate way of doing this
now and they have interesting things
like captures which do a little bit of
hashing as an alternative to pick these
images that have road signs in all right
just just do a little bit of CPU which
is interesting enough but yet so I think
going forward we're going to see fewer
of these deployed in a browser unless
they can find a way of getting around
these browser these new browser
restrictions but they might start to
find their way into more actual malware
right maybe instead of encrypting
everyone's files you just take over
their CPU for a while and make some
money that way or do both at the same
time or do you buy for the same time
yeah why not the free games thing is
quite classic because I mean we're all
used to just getting games for free and
expecting that purchases yeah when you
download an app it's got free access to
your CPU it could do this you'll know
because your phone will get hot and your
battery will go like this but that
happens with some games that are poorly
written anyway so how do we know that
you've got a hope I suppose that there's
some vetting process on the apps which
might hopefully detect this kind of
stuff but it's not always going to be
easy to find and so you can expect a few
of these to pop up from time to time
we're going to say document dot right
okay now that's it's going to write
nothing to the screen right so my
comment on my blog it's just going to be
a script that does nothing okay that's
not very interesting so let's do
something a bit more interesting our PHP
file takes the cooking gives an image
back so let's just show on a screen like
so image tag in HTML IMG is the image
tag